2021 was a record year for initial
public offerings 2
3888 firms raised 453 billion dollars
while going public the highest annual
deal volume ever and this year could
very well break those records here are
the ipos we're planning to watch in 2022
reddit the 16 year old social media
juggernaut behind last year's explosive
meme stock frenzy has reportedly been
eyeing a 15 billion dollar valuation
after a massive funding round in august
reddit confidentially filed paperwork to
go public this year but disclosed no
financial details and said it still
hasn't determined how much it's looking
to raise
another media company will be monitoring
closely trump media which is yet to
release a working product and plans to
go public this year via spec regulators
are already pouncing on the move with
the sec initiating an investigation into
stock trading and high level
communications last month no one's been
accused of wrongdoing but it's unclear
how this will affect trump's latest
money-making venture
also of note is discord which was
originally founded in 2015 to make it
easier for gamers to talk to each other
while playing video games however the
app gained notoriety as users began
using the platform for nefarious reasons
but discord has since instituted new
policies and roles completely rebranded
and now has an estimated 150 million
active users and though the online chat
service has yet to make an official
announcement investors have been eyeing
an ipo since the company ended
acquisition talks with microsoft in
april
we all know instacart as the popular
grocery delivery service that got even
more popular during the pandemic the
company was hoping to go public last
year but their new ceo delayed plans in
order to broaden services beyond simple
delivery and delve deeper into
advertising it'll be interesting to see
how this pans out its competitor
doordash had shares plunge about 15
since the first day of trading in
december 2020 but instacart has a big
advantage as retailers can promote their
products in search results and another
one in food vegan firm impossible has
raised nearly 2 billion since its
founding in 2011 and can now be found in
more than 22 000 grocery stores reports
indicate the company is eyeing a 10
billion dollar valuation signaling real
competition for fellow fake meat maker
beyond which listed on the nasdaq in
2019 and is worth about five billion
dollars
and then in the world of finance their
strike the payment processor founded by
billionaire brothers patrick and john
collison
for more than a year the company has
been teasing an ipo to rev up growth
with fresh public market cash the paypal
competitor was reportedly talking to
investment banks in september about a
market debut this year if the founders
decide to take the plunge stripe could
easily become one of the largest ipos to
hit the market
another one to watch in the space is
chime the digital bank based in san
francisco the company has helped talks
to go public at a valuation of 35 to 45
billion dollars as soon as march and
lastly there's tpg the private equity
powerhouse was founded by billionaires
james coulter and david bonderman and
holds outsized stakes in talent agency
caa vice media and spotify
in late december of 2021 the firm
announced plans to list on the nasdaq
exchange disclosing recently that it
hopes to raise as much as 1 billion
dollars in gross proceeds at a valuation
of 9.5 billion dollars in what's sure to
be one of the year's biggest public
market debuts
you